RETO MEIER: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a litany of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch the session "Developing
for Speed Minimizing
App Latency at Scale,"
then stay tuned because
here is the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You're a good developer
so you already
know the importance
of having a fast app.
Lower latency correlates to an
increase in user engagement,
sales, and user satisfaction.
COLT MCANLIS: Now latency is
the delay between a request
and its response.
And application
latency, specifically,
is how this delay manifests
and affects the end
user, which is important.
As little as a 100
milliseconds increase in page
latency can cause around
a 1% drop in revenue.
RETO MEIER: Which means
that the ultimate goal
is to manage latency
in a holistic manner
to maximize user satisfaction.
You know you've done a good
job when performance plays
no part in a user's experience.
They simply don't notice it.
COLT MCANLIS: A
good rule of thumb
is to focus your
attention on making
your most common
operations the fastest
and aligning behavior
with user expectations.
See, users intuitively
expect some operations
will take a bit longer, for
example, creating a new file
or saving one.
Now even for operation
when that's not the case,
or where the delay is likely
longer than they're expecting,
you can manage those
expectations by telling users
the operation may take a while.
RETO MEIER: From a
user perspective,
the perceived
latency is the time
spent interacting with the
UI, the actual latency,
and the difference between
their expectations.
There are some
great ways to make
your app feel like it's
loading faster without actually
decreasing its actual latency--
provide instant feedback,
animate straight transitions,
and cache your UI components so
that they appear immediately.
Showing your UI even if it
can't be interacted with
will decrease the
perceived latency.
COLT MCANLIS: If you want to
improve the actual latency,
the first step is monitoring it.
Google Analytics lets
you specify user timings
to investigate the
distribution of latency values
for different actions and
the difference in values
across different demographics,
including regional differences.
Another great tool
is Stackdriver.
Using tracing, you can view
latency numbers in real time,
plot it on a scatter
graph, and dig deeper
by selecting individual traces.
Stackdriver also
produces reports,
including sampling traces
at different percentiles,
for you to look at.
RETO MEIER: When you identify
a high latency function
or request type
that's CPU bound,
then profiling lets
you dig deeper.
Once you've identified
potential latency issues,
it's time to mitigate them.
COLT MCANLIS: One
great approach is
to find out where
your users are and put
your compute and storage
resources near them.
To help, use the
Google Cloud CDN,
or content delivery network,
to take advantage of Google's
globally distributed
edge points of presence
to catch HTTP load balanced
content close to your users.
RETO MEIER: Above all else,
focus on user satisfaction
with a holistic approach
that includes both front end
and back end.
If you're interested
in more ideas about how
to use Google CDN and details
on performing a performance
analysis on your apps, check
out the full talk on YouTube.
And if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Google
Cloud Summit coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]